nouvelle petite phrase de jean marie le
pen qui met le feu aux poudres
jean-marie le pen condamné par la
justice jean marie le pen à nouveau
condamné cet après-midi deux mois
d'emprisonnement avec sursis
8000 euros d'amendé et un an
d'inéligibilité pour provocation à la
haine raciale
decroix l'inégalité des races oui bien
sûr c'est évident toute l'histoire le
démontre elle n'ont pas la même capacité
ni le même niveau
l'évolution historique
les chambres à gaz sont un détail de
l'histoire de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
[Musique]
plainte de sos racisme contre jean marie
le pen
une plainte pour provocation à la haine
et à la discrimination ethnique suite à
des propos contre les roms qu'en juillet
dernier l'ancien leader du front
national avait évoqué une invasion de
rome dans la ville
[Musique]